hi my name is dr matias norvig i'm an
expert on old norse mythology at the
university of colorado
and today we're going to talk about
every god in
thor
[Music]
elements from old norse mythology have
been
taken and then used creatively in the
marvel universe to create a coherent
story where all things come together
first up thor
thor is
probably one of the most popular gods in
old norse mythology he was probably a
very popular god in the viking period
when scandinavians actually worship
these gods before they convert it to
christianity we can see this because
there are so many thor's hammers that
have been found in the ground from the
viking age i would say that the marvel
universe's version of thor is actually
quite true to
the thor that we have
in old norse mythology a lot of poking
fun of him as well someone's going to
amend that and stop saying that thor was
originally a ginger in the mythology and
this of course has something to do with
the fact that he creates lightning from
the sky and such things the ginger
represents the the fire in that respect
i'm not sure that they would necessarily
have attributed that much importance to
the color of his hair what we're seeing
in the marvel stories is more in this
situation of like making fun of thor by
cutting his hair and he's freaking out
and so on please can't i do not cut my
hair marvel thor is a little more vain
than the mythology thor what we have in
the mythology is a lot of descriptions
of his eyes in particular and how he's
got these very staring eyes that's
sometimes a bloodshot even the hammer is
called mjolnir this means grinder that
of course has some kind of connotation
we we understand that this is a hammer
that is designed
to
kill and destroy in the mythology what
we see is that the hammer can be thrown
and then it will return to him and once
it hits its object it will make
lightning in the marvel movie we see
how thor gets his hammer from his father
odin this is not exactly similar in the
mythology whosoever holds of this hammer
if it be worthy she'll possess the power
of thor
the marvel version of the hammer seems
to be very similar to thor's hammer in
the mythology except in the mythology
thor
doesn't fly by using the hammer he
mostly seems to ride a chariot but in
other contexts also just seems to be
walking
next up loki
in the mythology thor and loki are not
brothers they are
from different parentage loki is the son
of this
very nebulous giant named farberty and a
even more nebulous mother named levy he
represents
what will eventually become the chaos
that destroys the gods the marvel
representation of loki actually seems to
be more true to to the original very
complex character
i'm not even here
is this better
oh this is much better so what we see in
the mythology is that he morphs into
different beings we don't see him taking
on the shape
of like other gods or humans but he does
take the shape of other animals
unfortunately we don't see that loki has
any particular weapon like we do in the
marvel movies with the spear or scepter
what loki does have though is shoes with
wings on that makes him capable of
flying next up is odin
what we see is that odin is a very
powerful god in many ways he is also the
father of plenty of gods what we learn
in one story is that odin and loki
sometime in the far distant past
actually became blood brothers by mixing
their blood so there is a close
relationship between loki and and odin
but it's not one of being a parent and a
child the two gods in the mythology are
actually quite similar in different ways
they're both very trickster-like even
though odin is also considered sort of a
ruler of the gods odin can also change
shape into any kind of being so the
portrayal of odin as a one-eyed god
in the marvel universe seems to accord
generally
with ideas that are also present in old
norse mythology we know that odin gave
his eye
for wisdom in the myths he also has
multiple names some of these names
suggest that he's blind very thick books
could be written about odinn's ability
to see actually so when it comes to
odin's spear gonier this is
certainly something that is mentioned in
the mythology we also see
odin throwing his spear to
sort of mark a army as those who will go
join him in valhurt this
warrior
afterlife that he rules over
so moving on to hain dotler
[Music]
now he's an interesting character in the
mythology first of all he is the
watchman of the gods he lives on this
mountaintop called him in bjork which
literally means heaven's mountain
and from there he can see everything he
guards this rainbow bridge bibrust and
he has his horn that he will blow when
the evil forces the jertners or giants
they are attacking the gods i think
marvel does a great job at sort of
portraying heimdallr as very close to
what he is in the mythology he stands
watch
over the the bridge which you know in
the marvel universe is some kind of
technology that makes you capable of
moving between worlds in the vast realm
of space
next up is frica
[Music]
so in the marvel stories frika
is this
mother of thor and adopted mother of
loki and odin's wife now this is not
exactly the same
in the mythology in the mythology she is
odin's wife but she is the mother of
balder and herder she's not the mother
of thor in
the mythology
frigg
plays a very minor role as do all the
other goddesses i think in the marvel
universe what they have essentially done
is that they have combined a little bit
of frigg from the mythology and a little
bit of freyja from the mythology freyja
as as a goddess seems to have had a
relationship to war and battle so
there's like a fierce element to her and
then on the other hand you have frigg as
this loving mother and combined this
becomes a loving mother who fights to
protect the people she loves
so let's talk about sif
in the marvel universe she plays a
important role as a friend of thor and
someone who also has a crush on him
whereas in the mythology she is actually
thor's wife and that's really all we get
about her
moving on to malekith and the dark elves
now the interesting thing about malakith
is that there's no mention of this
figure in old norse mythology and the
name does not appear particularly nordic
either the dark elves on the other hand
are mentioned in nordic mythology mostly
they are conflated with the dwarfs or
considered some kind of underworldly
beings those who have created the marvel
universe they have sort of gone with
that idea that that there are these dark
elves and they are you know very evil in
in many ways moving to a3 one of these
dwarf characters in in the marvel
universe he does have some background in
old norse mythology we know an a3 from
one of the versions of the story about
how the dwarves create thor's hammer and
odin spear go near and a bunch of other
uh really important items that belong to
the gods in the marvel universe he's
created the glove that thanos
has the situation where
thanos melts eitri's
hands there's nothing similar in the old
norse mythology
what we do have is that a tree on the
other hand punishes loki when loki loses
his bets with him the gods say look you
can't take his head but you can sew his
mouth shut
next character is hella
now in old norse mythology her name is
just hell
and
she's probably more a place than a
person or god when she was born odin
in this context called all father then
gave her
the realm called nippleheimer
now that means the missed world so in
the marvel universe on the other hand
what she
seems to be is sort of like the unwanted
daughter of odin he's banished her to
another realm the banishment seems to
accord pretty well with the mythology
but the personal relationship uh does
not
next up is laufey
in the old norse the name will be
pronounced le vey
and this literally means sort of like a
leaf island
now in
old norse mythology a larvae is a female
name
so
this is assumed that this is a goddess
that we're talking about actually it
appears to me that
a
the marvel
giant ice giant um has essentially been
uh modeled over
several different concepts in the
creation of the world in old norse
mythology there is this giant called
emir who creates cream thursa then that
means something to the effect of frost
ogres the
mythology in the original language in
which it is written the word that
they're using for giant is jerktun and
that
means something like cannibal and not
really giant
talking about sir
now again he's one of the few giants
who's actually a giant he's huge in old
norse mythology and
he wields fire we know him from the end
of the world ragnarok he comes out of
the ground there's a precipice that
opens
and all kinds of evil things come out of
it and with it also this fire giant who
has a flaming sword that he uses to
basically
cut the sky apart and make everything
burn so the role that certa has in in
the marvel
universe it i think is actually quite
similar to the role that he has in old
norse mythology
but rakhner is not going to happen
without him but
the difference is that you can't really
trick fate so when we see that thor
prevents ragnarok by stealing his crown
and and all that stuff that's not
something that you could expect
happening in this faded universe that is
old norse mythology that's just not
possible
if we interpret the marvel universe from
the perspective of old norse mythology
it falls in line in the sense that the
marvel universe is telling us that well
if you mismanage your family if you
don't
make sure to make your children feel
loved for instance well then you do end
up with the ragnarok situation